dagegen kann ich noch gar nicht was ich
weiß doch was mich glücklich macht
herzlich willkommen zu einem video auf
das ich mich sehr sehr sehr fordert ihr
seht ihr leben jemals l wenn dieses
video online kontakte mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit schon mein interview
mit marcel gesehen da fällt ihr das
nicht getan
marcel hat beihilfen mitgespielt und
zwar bei zwei von den beliebtesten
folgen auf youtube aber mit 6,8 und
einmal 3,6 millionen aufrufen und dann
habe ich mir gesagt was machen wir
lassen wir doch einfach mal marcel auf
seine eigene hilfe folge reagiert
das wird weh tun die leute müssen wir
müssen gucken mit dem verhältnis
[Musik]
das sind meine lieblingstiere ist alles
für mich gemacht hast bester ich würde
doch alles für mein problem tun ja mein
kumpel würde alles für den punkt
natürlich habe ich an
da liegt er auch so heftig also leute
schaut euch unbedingt die interviews an
leute damit wir euch hier nicht spoilern
denn jetzt voller war okay ich wollte
vielleicht schaut euch die interviews an
ich habe ich gewarnt diese geschichte
hier an seinen lippen ist nicht etwa
weil er nicht besser weiß und nicht von
dem ort la belle gehört hat nein das
haben sie mir einfach drauf geschminkt
sie haben ihm einfach herpes drauf
geschmückt ja es ist alles für mich
gemacht hast ich würde doch alles für
mädchen trug das ist vielleicht
weglassen brigger diese szene ist schon
schwer es ist da dieses ziel jetzt echt
wert gibt ihr das oder noch die sahne
der erste das durchgestanden ja ich weiß
nicht wirklich
es war richtig gut
ist auch so eine sache kommen es dir so
gerne mag aber so langsam bin ich
wirklich was was du bist toll alter nach
fünf kilo süßigkeiten hat das waren
gerade mal 25.000 kalorien ja das ist ja
nicht aufhören zu essen
an der stelle noch mal dein kommentar
ist jedoch sowie die samische
wahrscheinlich wollte man muss bedenken
diese szene wurde auch ganz ganz
aufgedreht ja ja ganz ganz aufgedreht
wird bestimmt von 6 x 6 x und die sahne
ist mehrfach zu laufen
ich habe das war doch überhaupt nicht
viel
es ist doch alles nur für dich es ist
einfach die absolute härte wirklich muss
ich muss sagen eine sache die mich
tatsächlich depressiv macht das ist
grund für depressionen wie diese sahne
da schmilzt das ist wirklich eine sache
die kann ich nicht tolerieren
wobei ich sagen muss die musste für
extra ein ganz ganz engel klein ist ja
ja das war nicht ihre eigene sie musste
das wirklich das richtig schön ich habe
so viel mühe gegeben es war nicht damit
zurecht dass wenn essen auf seinem bauch
gelegt und du aufstehst runter fällt
eben ihrer schulter weil sie nicht
weiter ist das auch ein schönes bild
haben wir sie in den gezwungenermaßen zu
eng klamotten hier ein bisschen sagen
ein trauriges bild für die menschheit
du bist doch meine große liebe ich werde
alles für dich tun das weißt du da
wandelbar
ich bin halt eine große liebe dann
fressen
ok als mord und frisst halt's maul
kommen wir nicht an mit liebe sagen wir
nicht an treue liebe geht mit zucker in
den direkt in die blutbahn liebe ist
diabetes der mästet der liegt ne das ist
muss ich eigentlich hin
eigentlich weiß ich nicht aufgeben
musste
das war so das unterbewusstsein was da
gesprochen hat aber so bruder muss ja wo
aber wohin jetzt einfach nur in die
arbeitslose ist arbeitslos ja ja jede
andere natürlich auch wir kennen die wir
kennen alle die wichtigen tagtäglichen
arbeit termine die arbeitslose haben man
muss das einfach mal zu deiner nicht vor
anderen arbeitsstellen seit ashley mit
louis zusammen ist hat sich die
19-jährige sehr verändert was nicht nur
auf begeisterte der blick auch der blick
direkt auf das eine gute freundin halten
sieht einen sieg macht ein bisschen
zugelegt mehr rückt ein merkmal mit
denen achtungsvoll blick aller zeiten
respektlos und dieser short dann auch
noch dazu ja ja ja das war dass dies
auch mit sich machen das ja aber leute
schaut die interviews wie gesagt da
haben wir auch schon festgestellt
darsteller werden schon unter druck
gesetzt und manipulieren die auf jahre
und heute gezwungen das zu machen
wie sie auch noch immer hält soll ich
das abbauen oder soll ich noch leiden
zufolge also sie beginnen zu den satz
also ich will wirklich nicht sagen dass
du fett geworden ist aber schaut es mit
seinen abwertenden blick an und es kommt
danach auch nichts merken also sie
wollte den satz einfach wirklich nur
verwenden um mir zu sagen du bist
wirklich fett gewonnen
ja und dann dem besten mann habe zwei
jahren diabetes und muss ein bein
amputiert werden da ist er leute der
fest wenn man der beste man habe ja
bisher auch und dann noch mal unter die
arme und unterstützt wenn man nicht mehr
kann
wenn du nicht mehr kannst du hast schon
5000 gegessen dann dreht noch näher man
ja auch erstmal noch mal die
gummibärchen schlimmer
ich finde ich finde auch das bild sogar
typisch rtl
es liegt alles auf den tisch es reicht
nicht dass irgendwie ein joghurt eis
muss die jumbo packung sein
die sanierungs- und hoffen natürlich
noch sein und es muss noch drei weitere
xxl das ist der laden so ein produkt
wirklich krieg wirklich schmerzen wenn
ich diesen politiker was ist das
kaufen und das netz geholt
ich habe ihre lieblingsorte jetzt kommt
diese szene meine lieblings blog yamani
[Musik]
nicht abgestoßen
ich hab nicht so auf mehrere freitag war
leute das ganze wird wirklich noch schön
man bedenkt diese ganze sache die sie
dann sich rein schaufelt musste sie
wirklich erst hat sie gleich mehrfach
mehrfach mehr war und ihr macht dieses
ganze szenen ja voll und ganz auf eine
kamera heißt senat muss 56 78 mal
durchgespielt werden und in dem
schlafzimmer war er praktisch der
lebensmittel raum und da waren die
ganzen macht ungefähr 15 packungen nur
so davon sagt ja nie wer da was ist in
dem moment durch den kopf gegangen war
wurde ihr diese dinge gegeben hast und
sie sagt ja nie meine lieblings kurz
nachdem sie sich schon muffins chips
pudding in eine packung und alles andere
eingezogen na ja da muss ja bedenken
hinter der kamera musste sich dass er
mehrfach sein und ich dachte einfach nur
alte platzt aus allen nähten gleich
weil dieser sound dieses das mache ich
das machen will stößt ist traurig sagt
oder es ist einfach so die luft die so
entweicht wenn die süßigkeit verein
drückt er da ist kein kaum mehr dabei
das kann ich nicht wirklich nur noch
süßigkeit rein und luft die und war in
all ihren ich weiß doch was ein
komischer glücklich macht das mal
herzlich klären ich bin gegen die götter
lieben auch ein mann der sich auch gut
merken frauen wollen ein mann der gut
nicht im bett ist angemessen drei
stunden später luis erfreut sich am
anblick seiner traumfrauen für ihn gilt
je dicker desto besser welcher mensch
egal ob auf dicke frau schaut sich so
was anfangen dies ja nicht schlimm
sag mal die anderen mit den papieren
wird er von weit hinten
der schmerz schmerz wächst der schmerz
intensiviert
das macht nichts war ja das macht mich
glücklich
du musst ja noch spielen du musst ja
wirklich noch so tun als wäre es geil
der zuschauer weiß ja das ist alles noch
die eine oder andere wissen zumindest
aber dass du dass du sitzt ja nach vorn
du musst das ja wirklich in dem moment
geil finden
du musst es ja geil finden um bei dieser
einen mit dem töpfchen ich habe am
kaffeetisch willkommen ich hab gesagt es
kann nicht sein das kann echt du weißt
du so eine geht ja noch irgendwie aber
so einem zäpfchen die da eben gegen das
sumo ringer position da steht was ist
daran so sexy
an dieser stelle mache ich habe leute
wir werden nämlich auch noch eine
reaktion zu deinem zweiten hilf mir
video drehen die kommt dann auch
demnächst auf einem kanal leute nicht so
schnell sind wie gesagt was held in der
beschreibung von den kicken auf dem
fahrrad hier hat fröhlich
vorstellungsvideo klum könnte mein knie
bis der strauß kurs gut
[Musik]